serve with a single tag so what the
player tracking the zebra has developed
does is each player has a chip in their
shoulder pads an RFID chip we put two
tags on the shoulders of every player
and we track all those movements through
receivers that are around the stadium 25
times a second and it can track the
position the speed the acceleration of
every player all throughout the game
they're constantly measuring those data
points - to really understand for the
first time at a granular level what an
individual player does during an NFL
game the second the player puts on his
pads he's being tracked he walked out
that door in the field he's just a blip
on the screen the NFL is collecting all
of this data on the players running
around how fast they run where they run
exactly what routes that they're running
it's about the information that we can
now gather about an individual athlete
we're really treating each athlete as
specifically as possible RFID chips are
going to have a huge impact on talent
evaluation one of the big things that
the league and the players are going to
need to figure out together is what
happens with all this data
I mean imagine I'm an NFL player and my
team suddenly knows because they're
tracking me it's such a granular level
that I'm not as strong as I used to be
I'm not as fast as I used to be and my
contracts up this year how does that
negotiation go in the future it's a real
issue of concern for the players unions
and I I think you're actually going to
see the players than the unions push
back on some of this a little bit say a
wide receiver is coming off an ankle
sprain you're gonna know before the game
and during the game of what speedy is
going it's gonna inform your decision of
how much you should be on the field you
know smart teams don't really look in
traditional measurables they care about
play speed now you have play speed
I think the measurements like the
40-yard dash the vertical they're gonna
become even more obsolete because of
this technology now coaches are gonna
have play speed in front of them and
that's all they really care about
and once you have the data then you can
run the experiment then you can
hypothesize that if I focus lineman's
training on explosive speed techniques
that I might be able to get some
benefits in the run game because they
get off the ball faster you can tie in
your cornerback on a blitz so you have
to choose which defensive back you're
sending out to the quarterback well now
you know exactly how long it takes them
to get there I think what happens in
years to come where there's new
technology things that haven't been
invented is this bringing together of
video real time player tracking in
virtual reality for years we said things
as fans like oh that guy's slowing down
or man he is fast now we can actually
quantify those with real numbers we can
say well you know what this receiver
used to get out on the deep route at
this speed and it opens up a whole new
way of looking at the game